good morning it's Tuesday so my first
novel Looking for Alaska was published
in hardcover almost exactly 18 years ago
and back in 2005 here's how traditional
publishing generally worked at least for
first-time authors like myself your book
would come out in hardcover and then if
it sold well enough 12 to 24 months
later it would come out in paperback
this is not actually the American
paperback of Looking for Alaska which I
couldn't find this is the Bulgarian
Edition but basically the same thing
just different letters and this is still
how many books are published but I'm not
sure that it should be incidentally the
paperback for my new book The
anthropocene reviewed is about to come
out and I will be live and in person in
Miami Florida to launch the book on
March 23rd tickets in the doobly-doo so
numbers I'm bad at math so I have to
pick round numbers let's say the average
hardcover cost thirty dollars the
average paperback twenty dollars now
hardcovers are somewhat more expensive
to print they have certain bells and
whistles the bindings a little better
they might have a subtle Tuatara
debossed onto the hardcover Etc but they
don't cost like ten dollars more to
print so hardcovers are more profitable
per unit sold than paperbacks like if I
get three or four dollars per hardcover
sale I might get two dollars per
paperback sale also Publishers and
bookstores have higher margins per
hardcover sold but paperbacks because
they are less expensive tend to sell
overall more books so from a publisher
and bookstore perspective hardcover
first publishing makes a lot of sense
both because it allows Publishers to
make more money on the first year of a
book's life and because it allows them
to find out which books are likely to
have a large enough audience to make
paperback publishing Pro profitable side
note paperback publishing didn't even
really exist until 1935 and it didn't
become a big deal until the armed
services editions of paperbacks were
distributed by the million to soldiers
during World War II so you know
publishing can change it just tends to
change kind of slowly so back in 2005 my
entire goal for Looking for Alaska was
to sell enough coffees to make it to
Paperback because that meant it would be
in print for an extra couple years I was
working at bookwest magazine at the time
and so I knew that the vast vast
majority of novels sold fewer than a
thousand copies but Alaska sold about 6
000 copies in its first year and did
make it to Paperback and now 18 years
later it's still in print and these days
people expect to be able to read it
however they want whether that's a 20
hardcover or a 13 paperback or a 12
audiobook or an 11 ebook people want to
read how they want to read but I want
people to read in their preferred format
because that makes it more likely for
them to enjoy the book and recommend it
to friends and family we which
ultimately is why Looking for Alaska is
still in print right like it's not just
good for readers when they have their
ideal reading experience it's also good
for authors so I understand the
immediate business reasons for
publishing hardcovers first but in the
long run we want readers to love reading
whether they're reading ebooks or
audiobooks or paperbacks also you can
specialize for format like the audiobook
of the anthropocene reviewed has a
couple different reviews that need audio
to work the paperback will have my
review of ginkgo trees and the first art
made in space because I wanted to put
them there the hardcover has a secret
review on the last page where I review
The Annoying Thing where they're like
hey did you like this book you might
like John's other books so yeah part of
me Wishes the paperback had come out
when the hardcover did but I'm
absolutely thrilled that the paperback
is coming out at all also it means that
the large print edition will no longer
be confused with the paperback and I
won't get emails from people saying why
is the font so big in the paperback so
that that'll be nice however you've read
or might read my books thank you for
keeping them around and for allowing
them to live lives I never could have
imagined 18 years ago hope to see a lot
of y'all in Miami and Hank I will see
you on Friday